what is sorry
what is happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch today from
cartoon hooligans what if godzilla vs
kong
ended like this i'm sure this is going
to be a very serious take from cartoon
hooligans i just want to throw it out
there
that um i was almost a hundred percent
right about how
the fight concluded and uh
dang that godzilla would win the fight
and then mecca would show up and then
kong would take out mecca and then
they'd be like i'm cool with you dogs
you're the monster whisperer man next
movie you're gonna have to call it
otherwise your credibility is gonna be
destroyed
what i can also guarantee is that this
is probably a very common prediction for
that movie
i don't think so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i'm not impressed
[Music]
restore the spider
check out verse link in the description
to become cartoon hooligans patron
that's how we should advertise our
patreon
it's got two
he's got a smile he's got his gojira
smile
are they about to make out or something
i bet they are yeah hard and
wet yes yes
yes yes yes yes
a-plus a-plus
hold it up and pride
hillary is so much fun man
but you guys are married now
uh
[Music]
oh
oh buddy no yeah
hey he doesn't have hairy cheeks hairy
cheeks no
cheek hair
berry cheeks
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hahahahaha
that's how i bet a lot of people
on the team harry cheeks feel i mean
once again great job to cartoon
hooligans for uh
all the amazing work that you guys put
in here it felt like
kind of mature for for some angles he
had
kong saying you make me wet and hard
yeah he was very horrendous
i feel like cartoon hooligans is usually
a little more family friendly with some
of their humor
they wanted to go harder with this damn
they did they went
hard with the gvk crowd it's funny with
the not impressed moment
uh of pulling that from schneiderka
cause remember when this movie was
getting
review bombed by fans of the snyder
verse if they were to change that in the
actual movie
do you think snyder fans would have been
like
well looks like godzilla versus kong
people
are part of the snyder verse now i mean
how cool would it be if superman
fought god is there a comic like that
there's some comics right
man like fought like king kong or
godzilla's guy or something like that i
feel like superman
could be called in to take on godzilla
pretty handily that seems like a
superman level scenario
it's fun to have a snyder reference in
here especially
considering the fact that godzilla vs
kong's fight had similarities to bvs
of how batman beats superman but then
superman beats
the third threat doomsday after they
have to work together but superman
ultimately delivers the final blow
having a little reference in there
works or it's just a little funny thing
that they included in here
we're just yammering on about nothing i
think it
works but the thing is if you were to
put a moment like that
in the actual movie then you would have
two camps of people you would have the
camp of people who's like oh clearly
adam wingert and company
are big fans of the snyder verse but
then you'd have the other half of people
who were conspiratorial who were like wb
just put that in there to try and get
the snyder fans back on godzilla versus
cog's side they're just pandering
no matter who wins wb seems to keep
losing that's true
now godzilla in kong mating i like it i
want it
that kind of would have been my jam
if in the end in the actual they hooked
up and then they
had it's because we were like his baby
godzilla gonna be in there we've had son
of kong
we've had godzilla's kid but we haven't
had a kid of both of them we haven't had
a hybrid kaiju
of the two but that would imply that one
of them is female yeah well
you know godzilla has been a female in
the past or at least
uh able to fertilize and lay eggs
so we could just pull that rolling
emmerich cannon right back in like
everyone's been wanting
it's it's a matter of time you know
movies come back around
eventually there are going to be those
articles of like you know the 1998
godzilla is not as bad as you think it
is
and it's already begun starting today
hell yeah it's an underrated gem
people any any movie you forgot about is
an underrated gem
this is what happens when you try to
take a cartoon hooligans
comedy video incredibly serious because
think about it in the movie
kong was lonely he lost his people he
lost his
island he lost it all man and then
here's godzilla
who i think's pretty lonely too and you
think about it they're both
lone silent types and they're very
different from one another and you know
i feel
so much sympathy for kong i feel like
they complement each other well that's
what was exciting about seeing them team
up together in fact they could have
defeated mecca godzilla and
then started making out with each other
i think that would have been the way the
movie really
most naturally could have ended
naturally naturally because it kind of
ends a little too abrupt from yeah
it's kind of weird and i think it could
have just used that extra final stamp
especially because
you see godzilla with some emotion in
here he gives a full-on smile at one
point
this gave me so many questions both
about the implications for the greater
monster verse but also why
at the end of this video didn't godzilla
honor the union i could already see the
sequel
you don't even have to change the title
godzilla versus kong is a divorce
drama then how great would that be it's
the kramer versus creamer of monster
verse movies that's what we haven't done
yet i know they have that
bbs dick superman in court we need to do
godzilla and kong in divorce court
that's right man that's
the final frontier monsters will collide
in in in litigation well i think we
added on to cartoon hooligans videos
ourselves you know what you guys should
do is subscribe to cartoon hooligans if
you haven't done
so already it'll make your life better
than ours subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell
hit that like button smash someone's
face last but not least
i want to shout out today sarah campbell
you got two great names here when i hear
the name
sarah i instantly think of sarah connor
sarah connor
mother of the savior of the resistance
in the terminator franchise one of the
most badass female characters of all
time
and campbell like the soup and it's
comforting so you got the protective
mother
badass athletic nature side of you and
you also have
the warm soothing nostalgic comforting
side
as well so sarah i just think you got
the perfect name you are aptly named and
i
love you for your name alone i don't
even know what you look like but i
imagine you're one fine piece of ass
should i cut that out do you think
she'll count i think she will
appreciate that you're one fine piece of
ass